in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast young man
returning guest your people have been
asking for you back and literally just
like clockwork
we got your hospital back on
specifically to to magic and water boy
Alex so last time Hospital was on here
he was describing a type of guy
specifically his clientele that he has
and I was like man you talking about my
boy Alex listen to podcast I might
already know David in his head is like
Alex I knew he was gonna and then you
mentioned it too he's like I have a
friend and he's about to start talking
about me and immediately started talking
about me and my that's that's this guy
right here and I think like the the cool
thing is is that you know the last time
we did that podcast I you know I I
rarely read the comments right every now
and then ever since quarantine I have a
little more time so I'm starting in the
comments like I got time and I didn't
realize how common it is specifically
for for people that you help out the the
biggest comment that I kept on reading
was that's me that's me and I'm starting
to realize that it's it's a majority of
Doom's like it's not just like oh a few
people here and there have social
anxiety specifically when it comes to
women and approaching them it's a
majority of guys they just hide it very
well and they lie about it because I
meet a lot of dudes who are very cocky
right they go oh yeah when I talk to
these [ __ ] and then you see them in
person's like what am i me my rap song
you know the same thing though like when
I did the other podcast when I talked
about my relationship and then you go
through the comments and there was so
much people like oh I'm dealing with the
same thing I'm dealing with the same
thing I had this I'm like damn dude [ __ ]
yeah meh so I brought Cosmo in here to
have a conversation with you just to
kind of dig deep and see what you do for
me because I have a lady I'm just gonna
by saying David I absolutely love you I
think that what I was talking about
before is your raw you're open and when
we do the podcast like we don't talk
about like what we're gonna do and I had
a lot of fun and not - we're gonna start
it like this cuz
go ahead and do it but I got like two
DMS from your fans and one of them was
like a suicide letter
oh [ __ ] got that deep he was like hey
man perfect timing I just got through a
breakup right now and I'm not gonna lie
I've been taking a lot of pain pills and
I've been like very depressed and when
you opened up about like your mom and
all of that stuff I thought you're gonna
be like mr. cool guy and you you gave me
hope so I know that I'm we're trying to
be like fun and all that but do like
thank you for having me on cuz like I
got some pretty intense DMS yeah and
I've never had so many Asian people
follow me
yeah it's interesting because I was very
purposeful with the title cuz I put in
pickup artists on there because I wanted
to see how people reacted and it's
because specifically on the podcast he
says that people have a very interesting
outlook when it comes to that title and
what he does so okay well let's see
let's see if you guys listen to the
podcast and let's see if we could change
that perspective because that was a few
the top comments it was when I heard
David was going to bring on a pickup
artists I assumed that he was gonna be
like this well let's let's see how they
react and it was it was very warm and
inviting people loved it yeah cuz we
started off with going [ __ ] pickup
artist and then you're like thumbnail
was like pickup artist Kosmos so yeah it
was good when you put that on David
pickup artist I thought it was gonna be
something like yeah cuz you posted that
picture of Dan I'm like dude this will
really get Dan on the podcast bro no no
I'm like what we were talking about
before like a lot of people have a
perception versus reality which I'm
gonna go over that with you right like
we talked about it dan Bilzerian is an
[ __ ] like we don't trust him he's one
of the most loyal kind amazing human
beings you are not gonna get any kind of
life from him now I know these Hollywood
producers hey I'm RELIGIOUS I love you
this and that don't worry about it you
go to their house party and they're a
[ __ ] snake mm-hmm I love people who
are authentic yeah that's awesome
well on today's podcast I'm just gonna
have you guys
conversation I want you to show your
magic Cosmo because I feel like people
felt a little bit of it during the first
podcast and you know I'm just genuinely
curious too I mean last time we were
talking about it earlier just before we
started this podcast he was talking
about how he like yelled David I'm gonna
take you to a bar and I'll make you a
purchase 15 win I like nah bro we ain't
doing that I'll pass out we still have a
third plastic oh I'm good at working my
magic I might get him out guys bars are
closed no babies no so cool well I'm
just gonna be a bystander and I'm
observed yeah so let's get into it all
right okay no because I just I have got
no direction but yes so what's going on
in your life so you know before I even
ask like tell you that a lot of people
who are watching right now definitely
will empathize with whatever you say so
I want to start by saying thank you so
much for opening up to whatever you're
gonna say or thanks for coming yeah on
our last podcast David talked about his
dad never said I love you to him I
talked about my mom issues my divorce
like we went all in so before even going
into like your situation whoever's
watching this right now and has gone
through any kind of depression or has
felt heartbroken you're not you're not
alone like there's a lot of people going
through it and um let's get into it yeah
yeah yeah I don't know I don't know
where my problem stems from to be honest
like even family wise like so my parents
divorced when I was four
but they were so good and making it to
where we saw we saw each of them just
the same amount as each other
we've had real good relationships we
still do have good relationships my dad
and my mom are still like best friends
like it's to the point where my
half-sister from my mom when she got
remarried my actual dad is my
half-sisters Godfather right so our
family's been super close so I don't I
don't know if it stems from that I'm not
too sure I I don't really know what
started all of this but I remember I
told David in one of our podcasts it was
like
ask me what are you scared of and I was
like I don't know I think I've been
scared of so long that I don't even know
what I'm scared of anymore to you know
do that type of stuff so I don't know I
don't know how it were to start off okay
so I got you so what is your current
situation right now like relationship
status
yeah single I'm single okay and when's
the last time you had a girlfriend last
time at a girlfriend was about I think
that breakup was like two years ago now
two two-and-a-half years ago no two
years ago cuz I knew you when I was
doing the person yeah so about two years
ago maybe a little under two years ago
now okay and if you had a genie lamp
right now and you're like Cosmo I would
love if I had like a wish for this to
happen right now what would that be uh a
wish right now would to be be successful
and happy with obviously a girl that's
happy with me so you know I'm a real
[ __ ] so imma call you out right
now keep it real but I feel like you're
hiding a lot right now hiding a lot yeah
I feel like you're hiding and I feel
like you're being very general and not
like specific you know what I mean like
if you act like so like like what is it
about like so what is your top three
fears right now in women since we're all
talking about like the social life so we
can get like right into it right like um
you know what you know what let me let
me look I got you I got your for sure
did your ex ever call you loser
no did your ex ever cheat on you yes
there we go I found out after after yep
this is where it's gonna get deep right
guys and then a lot of guys are watching
right now this has happened to you and
it has nothing to do with you but let's
start there what happened when you found
out well so the story is is that I found
out because the person that she had sex
with told the sonne that's close to me
and after the whole relationship thing
happened that person told me about it so
that's how I found out and this was
probably
six months after we broke up but it was
like a it was like a nasty breakup
because the whole time too like in the
beginning of her relationship she was
she was cheating on her current
boyfriend while she was trying to get
with me and telling me like oh we're
gonna be in a relationship I just need
to break up with him I just need to
break up with him I'm going to break up
with him and that went on for like two
months
so she was cheating on him and then I
found out afterwards because the that
story of about the person that she had
sex with did come up during our
relationship because I questioned her
about it right and of course it was a no
no I never did I never did I never did I
never did and I found that it was true
afterwards so let me ask you this have
you ever felt well has she ever felt
jealous of you in the relationship like
as if that if you went out for a boys
night out or if you left somewhere she's
like my man is probably gonna get
scooped up by one girl and I will never
have him again and I can almost answer
the question probably not exactly okay
she always said I would never been a lot
of people I see we talked about in our
last podcast it's a good emotion why
don't we talk about it like it's bad if
I know that you're attracted to me my
gauge from another girl is if she's not
jealous she doesn't give up hey brother
build what I call it jealousy plot line
so if I knew you back then right and and
you're and you're telling me all this
I'm gonna be like yo let's do this real
quick I'm gonna invite like seven girls
and then let's do like a bunch of IG
stories or let's bring them around and I
want to see how your girl reacts right
so two things are gonna happen number
one she's gonna be like damn I never
found my man this attractive before I
must be [ __ ] up right now and number
two she's gonna be like is he gonna
leave me I got a what I gotta up my game
right now cuz when you don't have that
thing that like oh my god he's gonna
leave me she's going to always do that
every girl will always do that we talked
about it intimacy passion
and commitment you had no passion no
intimacy you had just commitment but
guess what the commitment didn't last so
he talked about before David he has zero
out of three yeah we talked about it
like most American guys have one out of
three so anytime that you meet a girl if
she's gossiping about her ex it's a big
red flag okay I should be taking my I
got I got 10-year relationship and I
don't even want to tell you what my ex
did to me but in this podcast mean David
had I never should talk to her I never
said she's a bad person you know what I
said it was my fault
mmm-hmm I put all the blame on myself
and I'm going to now readjust and take
action what happened okay cool
I began to get too cocky and too
confident that I had that attraction
which is passion we had that so much but
where I started to [ __ ] up was a
commitment we are diametrically opposed
you need to come halfway into me and I
need to come halfway into you I caused
too much jealousy therefore the
commitment started to get very anxious
your ex and brother correct me if I'm
wrong she's like I can do anything wrong
and he's gonna come back to me I don't
have anything to worry about because he
don't got no other options now like
imagine if every single weekend you're
like now I'm working with a dating coach
his name is Cosmo we're going out on a
party bus to Vegas 15 20 girls I'm
you're gonna be monogamous
I'm not saying cheat on your girl but
now one thing gets triggered imagination
the best movies that you guys see can
you figure out where the protagonist is
going in the first five minutes know if
you did you a to now you watch a movie
and go where the [ __ ] is this gonna go
you need to trigger her imagination so
my man left what is gonna do right now
oh my god am i doing enough am i having
sex with him enough I need to step it up
do I need and then now
she starts to think about what she's
doing wrong we do three components
number one we think about what the other
person is doing number two were in our
head oh my god is the people on YouTube
liking me right now do I have anything
on my teeth
how am i how my army pants looking right
now did I wear shoes that are tight you
go into yourself you go into your brain
number three is the environment where am
I at right now right so every single
time that you operate in a social
gathering those three things are
happening one two or three women that
are really good in a relationship they
will always keep you at number two
self-conscious I'm doing something wrong
mmm-hmm damn I thought I was in good
shape
I gotta lose weight oh damn I thought
and they were gonna keep you in your
head mmm and that's where you don't want
to be there's very active things that
you can do and one of the things would
be to have her know that at any given
point in time you can lose me it's a
very healthy feeling we talked about it
I don't want to play games Cosmo oh my
god your techniques don't work I'm done
with playing games every single couple
that has a healthy relationship 5 10 15
years are playing games mmm it's very
healthy for you to have a little bit of
jealousy from your girl is it like for
you like a representation of like it's
like desire right because I feel like
after like relationships go for like 10
plus years and sometimes I look at these
relationships and I don't see that
desire in them every single day they
have a pattern my man is gonna leave at
9 a.m. he's gonna get back at 7 p.m.
we'll have sex on Thursday we have
breakfast here and there is a pattern
and the girl gets so bored that's when
every Hollywood movie what happens the
guy gets home from work early was like
oh my god my wife's been banged by
Latino
myself no but you know it's so
stereotypical it's like you have a
pattern you don't want to develop a
pattern with your girl most guys get
lazy and they're like nah I got her
already there's nothing that can happen
when you're predictable your
relationship dies hmm and there's a
sense of you nailed it David of having
that desire like damn like aren't like
like what what's gonna happen on
Saturday okay I haven't experienced this
but every single day we have it planned
out you're really walking on like a
dangerous line right there okay so um
you said so if everything's always
planned that's when it's bad absolutely
okay you have to throw in what Tony
Robbins says this sense of not having
any kind of predictability mm-hmm and
then that is what keeps humans going
forward I have been pursuing acting for
14 [ __ ] years you know what wakes me
up every day not knowing if I'm gonna
make it mm-hmm today might be my day
that keeps me going Billy Bob Thornton
on YouTube goes you know I'm very
grateful for being famous you saw it
right now
but I gotta tell you guys and Billy Bob
goes like this when I was coming up
those were the best days because I
didn't know what was ahead
hmm when he blew up it was so
predictable
Billy you're making seven million you're
doing eight films the next two years so
your whole life is planned humans will
die of boredom and that's a big part of
being in a relationship we feel like hey
Cosmo I want to take your seminar but
once they got the girlfriend they're
like I'm cool bro I'm like no you're not
and you know what happens and you know
you can disagree if you want to it's
like an open forum right now most guys
go I'm in a seven-year relationship and
they get out of a breakup and I go cause
money to hire you I go why you go I
haven't talked to a girl in seven years
my girlfriend was a devil I go do not
even blame it on your girl right now you
had the ability to continue to
and be social and talk to guys I have to
say this right now when you're in a
relationship make sure that you have a
lot of female friends where you can be
around that energy you can always be
loose and just in case something happens
to your girlfriend you go I'm
heartbroken for three weeks I'm gonna
cry but I'm good mm-hmm and the death
I'm getting dark right now where a lot
of suicides happen is when a guy goes
Cosmo I will never find a girl like that
ever Cosmo that was my soul mate Cosmo
that was my better half no it wasn't she
was on a journey with you now she left
and you're good to go my brother mm-hmm
and you want to know what girls don't
have a high suicide rate from breakups
did you know that mm mm man do you want
to know why it's the cool for guys to
cry yes or no no is it cool for women to
cry yes or no that's a yes kind of
promote yeah a girl cries you go it's
all good so guys are punished for
showing emotion mm-hmm I'm heartbroken
right now like I got through a 10-year
relationship and I'm like heartbroken
so I tell all my friends I'm like bro
are broken and all my friends know what
I coach and they don't try to lecture me
they go cause you need to cry I'm like
yeah bro I'm like not feeling good right
now dude I want to take night coolness
like 10:00 in the morning if you have
friends that allow you to emote and
allow you to get that out of your system
mmm in about three weeks you're like I'm
over my heartbreak you know what happens
with the suicide rate guys keep it in
you go out to a restaurant a bar hey how
you doing bro no I'm good bro but you
just got out of a like a really bad
breakup nah homie I'm good dawg I got I
got this girl and you hide it and you
hide it till really bad things happen so
I want to promote to everybody that's
like watching right now if you're a guy
I give you permission to like really
find three people in your life that you
can emo to that you can call and tell
the person on the other phone
by saying this I don't need any advice
right now and I don't need for you to
tell me what I'm doing wrong I need to
get this out of my liver my lung and let
me talk and then you have your grandma
your cousin your neighbor and you speak
and it's very very therapeutic and I
think that helped me a lot through that
breakup because I did my mom was one of
them like I went over there and I was
just like I just need to give you a hug
and cry for a little bit she's like okay
so I gave her a hug and I cried my
friend one of my best friends Patrick
and my friend Alfonzo McHale that what
you just said was what it was they
they're just like oh just tell us what
you're feeling so I just told them this
is how I'm feeling I'm sad because of
this this this and they just listen I
think that helped me a lot too with that
breakup especially them being there kind
of telling them like oh look you know
you were you weren't wrong in this spot
because as David knows when I talked
about that last relationship I always
used to be like oh I was doing this
wrong or this was my fault this is why
this happened this was my fault this was
my fault I did this so they kind of just
helped me throughout that that situation
with that so that did help what you're
saying right there I get because I had
those couple people that I just went to
talk to about it and they would just
listen and just sit there give me hugs
and about it's all good bro you're gonna
be good
oh that's I'm sorry and so were you
blaming your ex or were you saying
I [ __ ] up or what was your mindset my
mindset especially during our
relationship was I must be doing
something [ __ ] up this is why she's
acting like this I must be doing
something and then it was always like my
friends like no bro she's [ __ ] up
she's [ __ ] up I was like I don't know
I I should be doing like this then I
should act like this and so I feel like
towards the end of the reel after the
relationship when I was talking about it
more and stuff I kind of realized like
okay maybe I wasn't in the wrong the
whole time because that the whole
relationship but I was wrong so I was
always nervous like oh I'm gonna do
something she's gonna leave are tomorrow
might get a text saying that she's done
or something like this so I was always
nervous that whole relationship I swear
like [ __ ] my blood pressure felt like
it was up to out the whole time really
why's that I don't know I was just it
was one of the in the situation's like I
knew this girl for a long time she was
really
I was really attracted to her right
never in the in my lifetime expected
that I was gonna end up dating this girl
right so when it happened on my holy
[ __ ] I'm dating this person like I never
expected this to happen right so I gonna
look back at it I'm like I was kind of
just more like falling in and liked that
it was the person that I always felt
like oh I would never be with this girl
and I feel like that's why I stuck
myself in that situation the whole time
you literally got into I want to talk
about two things he said right now you
got into a relationship where you were a
fan and she was a celebrity mmm exactly
that's that's how it felt cuz I can't
tell you how many times in my head I was
like I can't believe I'm dating wait
when you meet a real celebrity let's say
like Scarlett Johansson Megan Fox if you
treat them like a normal person and in
your mind you go the average lifespan of
human of a human being is 28,000 days
you're gonna die just like I am if I cut
you you're bleeding you have to really
ground it to be like what am i doing
right now
like why are celebrities put so high if
every person walked around and saw Brad
Pitt I was like hey man I loved you in
this movie good [ __ ] and like with that
tone I was like all right I gotta go to
work bro I'm clocking in there would be
no celebrities yeah the reason why they
have so much power is because we're
giving that power to them mm-hmm they
don't have any power yeah oh my god oh
my god it's so good to meet you then
they suck that power away from you and
now they go well [ __ ] maybe I am better
than you
man now they start to take that powers
what your girl did to you you gave that
power she looked at you and she goes
okay this is [ __ ] will never
cheat on me I can keep that this
[ __ ] ain't going nowhere you
know what when I want some dick I'll go
here and there after you know I mean a
little rude right now but I'm just
saying that like her her mind was going
like oh I don't need to be on my a-game
nor do I need to be on my B game I could
be on my C game and still keep this guy
yeah
and that is why hanging around with
women I know you have a lot of female
friends we talked about that and that's
why your girl has that subconscious
attraction to you is because when you
have that ability to hang out with women
it always keeps your current girlfriend
on a kind of like she's not steady she's
like whoa whoa whoa away we'll wait a
minute what is he doing is he leaving
okay no I got to do it better and
they're trying to one-up themselves
which is a very good place to be mmm
yeah there was some more yet said like
she always felt like like you were
saying girls for like oh I know matter
what this guy's gonna stay around and
she I know she felt like that and I
remember the very last time because
every time that she would like oh we we
got to stop talking right I sat around I
moved and I waited and I waited and she
would come back and do that type of [ __ ]
the last time is the actually the time
that I totally like a look but I don't
want to be with you I don't want I'm not
gonna be with you anymore and just to
see her reaction change of like oh no
I'm sorry I messed up I messed up oh I
want to be what you I did I'm like this
is a completely different person from
the whole beginning of the relationship
so where's when you were saying that
before I'm like yeah that's literally
what the [ __ ] happened at the end when I
told her that I'm curious how many times
does she tell you that she's gonna leave
with me
yeah uh I think we talked about breaking
up one time before we actually did and
then that's when you said you mope -
right yeah so there was a couple yeah so
actually know what because the in the
beginning we weren't official she never
wanted to make it official but we were
oh my god everyone watching right now
please learn right now you know I love
you bro that is a huge [ __ ] red light
right there where you're keeping your
guy on the side to be like yeah I know I
don't want to tell anybody that women
are the first to be possessive and to be
like that's my man so if a girl is
telling you I don't want to make it
official it's a really bad starting
point into a relationship hey we talked
about this in our last podcast you came
in
without attraction and you started with
comfort and trust she didn't have that
like oh my god I'm getting aroused oh my
god my man might leave me oh my god I
have to look better I have to like be
better for him
she started with he makes me feel
comfortable mm-hmm
this other bad boy that I want to [ __ ]
he might leave me I don't feel
comfortable with him when you skip the
attraction phase this will most likely
happen
she will cheat on you hmm and let's say
that she doesn't cheat on you in a
female's mind she's like if my
imagination is not going wild right now
like if I'm not curious about like wow
David is doing all these podcast she you
know he has a lot of female friends it's
a healthy place to be for David's
girlfriend wife fiance fiance to be at
but what a society tell us no jealousy
is a bad emotion no men shouldn't cry no
we need to go against that you want to
make your girl feel jealous mm but you
never want to actually break that trust
like what you're saying make them too
jealous in the beginning you don't want
to take action mm you want to make her
mind very much like go oh my god what if
David gets cast for a show in Europe and
I can't see him for eight months that is
an attractive quality for a girl because
she's gonna do everything she can to
one-up her game David will go babe you
only cook for me one time a week why you
cooking from here every single day
that's what she's thinking she's going I
gotta step my game up right now Muriel's
food is not that great
[Laughter]
I hope you don't miss that part your
cooking's great I love it in the last
podcast we talked about David didn't
like cleaning so maybe your fiance would
be like okay baby you don't got to clean
anymore
she whatever it is for your girl she's
gonna want to be like I gotta do better
yeah and I don't want to put that on
women you gotta be like mm-hmm
I want to do better I want to lose
weight I want to look good for you most
men get the girl and they gain so much
weight cuz they're like she'll never
leave me
it's like ya know what I'm gonna keep
looking good because my mindset is Cosmo
Tommy
we might get divorced mm-hmm we might go
through a breakup and I need to be able
to pick up and have the ability to
attract other women and be around other
women do you think that a lot of guys
kind of miss they kind of mistake
comfort and trust as attraction do you
think that happens a lot cuz like when
they when they get comfortable with the
girl they think oh she must be attracted
to me then but that's probably not the
case they're confusing it that's so far
apart that is literally the worst
mindset that you can have when the girl
feels comfortable enough to burp in
front of you or to take her shoes off
and be better be barefoot and be like
you know what David you make me feel
very comfortable that is a very big red
light where you go wait a minute
I haven't billed no attraction right now
when you know that a girl has those
attraction triggers like going off is
when a girl is like hey thank you so
much and she's being a little awkward
she's being weird
um so yeah and she's beat she doesn't
want to [ __ ] up in front of you when a
girl is like this and she's like hey
David can get me arms just real quick
like yeah you know and she's kind of
like too comfortable it's a very
dangerous place to be and let me explain
to you how this works okay so we have a
formula called a 1 a 2 a 3 3 steps of
attraction a 1 you skipped you didn't
even
that because you didn't hunt for that
right mmm you didn't right mmm okay so a
one is you literally going out and
opening the girl you're going out
somewhere you're going I like that girl
I'm gonna walk up to her right now
it shows massive alpha qualities to be
like I'm gonna go out and get what I
want
mmm so a1 is about and I know guys girls
watching this I'm getting a little nerdy
right now but a one is about showing the
girl that you have the ability to get
rejected or to get humiliated and you're
fine with it you go okay cool so you
walk up to a girl we talked about my
opener last podcast hey real quick I
just wanted to come over and introduce
myself if you like you have really good
energy I listen to it it's a really good
opening line I have 15 really good
openers but I'm gonna go over one opener
right now but I have 15 really good
openers that you go in any single
environment so that's one of them and
the worst-case scenario is a girl goes I
have [ __ ] you I don't have good energy
and you go okay my bad yeah like you're
really not getting rejected think about
you going up to a homeless guy and going
hey bro here's $100 and a homeless guy
goes I don't need your money would you
feel rejected
you'd be like trying to help you out
yeah yeah like you're not gonna feel
rejected so the first phase of
attraction is you going out and hunting
and getting the girl that you want
second phase is what we call dhv
demonstrating higher value I have 24
techniques that I go over this so this
is like a law like a lot of hours to
master this craft but I'll give you one
example so you want so you do a 1 so
when you get into a 2 you have to
demonstrate to the girl why you have
what why you're a high value guy one of
the triggers is called pre selection you
have to let the girl know that you have
a lot of women in your life and you have
a lot of options and you're the type of
guy that says no more than he says yes
and through these stories you have to
communicate to the girl that I'm good
with or without you right now and a
story can be
very simple and she's like you never
want to ask a question right so I'll
roleplay with you you're gonna be a
really beautiful girl right now bra from
I'm gonna go like this you seem like
you're from the East Coast and then a
girl would be yeah yeah actually right
now is laughing you guys have that vibe
like you're from New York yeah one of my
ex-girlfriends was a fashion designer
you guys seem like you're into fashion
like I feel like you guys love fashion
and it's so funny let me get honestly
right now I need a female's opinion so
one of my homegirls wanted to fly me out
to Miami and I was like telling her I'm
like I feel really weird because I feel
like I should be buying the flight and
she goes Cosmo I have to be honest with
you right now every time I hang out with
you you cure my social anxiety like you
make me feel good so the the least that
I can do is I want to I want it for you
to come with me to Miami and I'm not
trying to hit on you Cosmo but you make
me feel comfortable so I want you to
stay in our condo with a bunch of girls
so I like on the phone I'm like all
right if that's what you want I'll go so
literally is one of the best trips I've
ever had going to Miami it was like 12
girls I was by myself everywhere I went
I got free drinks I got treated like a
king and at the end of the day I knew
that I need to make more female friends
because it opens up so many more doors
no so I'm curious about you I feel like
you hang out with a lot of guys you have
that vibe like you're like like a guy's
girl yeah I mean I have a lot of guy
friends I have like so you know I have a
couple of girlfriends not like a huge
can I just add miss something to you
right now I am whatever I'm gonna say it
out loud right now like you're really
cute
Thanks too bad you're not my type
I know but now I do
no no no I'm not talking about Alex you
got you guys caught what I was doing
right yeah I know okay so like I'm
talking to you as if you were the girl
mmm did you catch that or no I did but
then I got you got out of character but
that's what I'm saying is you want it
you want to cause that kind of tension a
lot of guys are like no dude I don't
want to talk about me and other women
and they want to play it very safe
high-risk high-reward
you have to be willing for the girl to
be like you're doing too much or being a
show-off and then you can kind of tone
it down and you can say a line like this
to be honest with you I'm really nervous
I find you're attractive so I'm trying
to show off to you and now you have the
ability to moe and now she looks at you
going I can trust you because that's
what I was feeling do you think that's
kind of what you meant by you know I was
actually really shocked there was a
there was a comment where girl wrote
like she really really likes pickup
lines right which I think like typically
a lot of people would think it's the
other way around
and there's that pickup line kind of
fall into what that does right there too
because I was surprised when a lot of
people agree with that they're like I
love pickup lines like [ __ ] that's the
exact opposite of what like I felt most
girls would say when you put that
thumbnail up I'm like David is gonna
corner me into a disaster you're good no
pickup lines means that you have a plan
right now we leave this podcast we go to
like a restaurant right now I'll make
you talk to four girls right now as long
as you know what to say you have a
couple stories you have like little
sound bites you can last in that
conversation if you're gonna go in and
be like what most women will tell you to
do
hey be confident and be yourself okay
I'm gonna be myself I'm going through a
bad breakup I feel like [ __ ] right now
and you told me to be confident don't
know how to do that what I coach is I'm
like let's have a story put together
like a
tell you my story about the girl
inviting me to Miami which is a real
story right so you have a roadmap where
to go and it protects you from a lot of
like um so where are you from what are
you doing I don't mean pickup lines like
going to Google and be like hey you know
like the corny pick-up lines I mean like
having a [ __ ] game plan every
millionaire that I know has a game plan
they have pickup lines they know what to
do they have strategies okay this week I
got to do that I got to go do this why
don't we have that in social dynamics
why I talked about it in in the last
podcast Tom Hanks one of the most
likable actors ever has pickup lines he
goes on Conan O'Brien then he went on
back in the days Jay Leno all this and
I'm like he's saying the same [ __ ]
story
and every time Tom Hanks and I open a
door the crowd laughs he knows that he's
eliciting laughter yeah he's not going
in going now Bramah be myself he knows
what to do and his publicist is going
don't talk about XYZ talk about that I
am offering people who are watching
right now to have a game plan mm-hmm and
the more beautiful the girl is the more
that you find her attractive the more
that we're going to short-circuit our
hands get like very sweaty we start to
go now we're not good enough we get we
get like very anxious like that's what
man do when you say something like like
demonstrating high value right like what
do you mean like specifically is that in
terms of like value in terms of what
what you can offer the girl is that what
you mean like no okay I mean that you're
letting her know that you're a high
value guy hmm you're demonstrating to
the girl that you're a high value guy
and in the end of a two which is dhv n--
right you know what happens your value
is higher her values lower so guess what
happens you have to build her up right
so you guys can have a normal
conversation so you know what you do you
make her dhv and
now she qualifies herself which is the
last step of attraction so you know you
do all right
I'm curious about you so like tell me
about your dreams tell me about you she
goes oh you know what I want to be a
nurse and now she'll start to prove to
you why she is a high value woman and
the last step of the last step of
Attraction look at David having
epiphanies the last step of Attraction
she comes to your level and you guys are
here even exchanged
mm-hmm I proved to you why I'm high
value now I feel like I'm a little bit
superior right now I feel like I've done
a really good job in demonstrating it
and now it's your job to tell me and
then you go like look I'm just gonna
tell you pickup lines right so I'm
curious about you tell me two
interesting things about yourself or you
know what you know honestly you got my
attention so like what do you want to be
when you grew up or like what is your
vision like what's your plan I'll be
your number one family what do you I
just had this flashback and I told the
story before right so when Muriel and I
were dating at the time I was dating
other people - she was dating other
people as well and so after a certain
point I told her that I'm just gonna
stop dating other people and then I just
want to connect with you only and that's
it but she kept on going back and forth
with this thing where she was just like
oh I don't know and she kept on
mentioning other guys oh my gosh she has
good game I love to get on a podcast but
that's what guy I'm sorry in job but
that's what guy should be doing what I
was telling you having that ability to
tell the girl I want to hang out with
you this weekend I have literally four
girls telling me to go to Vegas I don't
want to go to Vegas I want to hang out
with you let me know if you're around if
not I'm heading to Vegas you see you see
how that happens like she did it to you
yeah and it's interesting cause like
what happened was like when I was
talking to her on the phone and we had
this conversation and she just goes yeah
well like this other guy like he goes
mountain biking what and I I was like so
fed up I literally told her this I was
like I think you have something confused
and this is to quote what I said you
know something along the lines what you
were mentioning I was like I'm not
trying to find out if I'm good for you
I'm trying to figure out if you're good
for me I told you how I feel so now the
balls in your court so you figure out
what you want to do and then I hung up
the phone and the next day she was like
hey let's meet up and then she was like
I want to meet up all talking she goes I
want to be in a relationship when I
the phone I was like the next day she
was like well I want to I want to be
together and I was like oh [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] I've been right now yeah you did
that organically yeah it was I just I
teach that systemically so a guy that
takes my bootcamps he takes he goes into
my group he would know how to say that I
wouldn't
I wasn't born with whatever you were
born with but in that moment David you
knew what to say
I didn't growing up I didn't know about
pick-up lines you you're your brain when
I'm [ __ ] sick of this girl talking
about guys I'm not you look I'm trying
to find out if you're compatible with me
a lot of guys don't know how to do that
that's why you need routines cuz you go
oh I'm at this step in a game the girls
doing a [ __ ] test to me meaning I want
to see how you react you took ownership
you took alpha I'm so sorry I'm gonna
apologize I don't know if I'm confused
or you're confused I'm not looking for
like for me to get approval from you I'm
looking to see if you fit in my life and
then you hung up the phone it is exactly
what we are talking about leaving a girl
going oh my god he might get another
girl tomorrow hmm
I need to step my game of the jealous
it's fascinating you literally just
nailed it because I couldn't see that's
the thing too is we were talking about
this how you know when people asked on
this podcast like yo David how do you
get I was like I don't [ __ ] know like
I don't know how to put it into words so
it was always hard for me to give that
advice I didn't know what the [ __ ] I was
doing you know it was just it happened
and they don't organically work so it's
so interesting how what you're saying
right now is literally what happened
with one of how I got Muriel and the
jealousy things making a lot of sense to
me now too because I feel like a lot of
my relationships has reason why they
ended guys let's give it
gonna be like energy a lot of my
relationships ended because my whole
entire time I'm in that relationship was
alright try to make sure they're not
jealous of anything oh so now it's
making more sense when I'm hearing my
okay maybe I was doing that wrong then
why why did you feel that way what were
you thinking I just in my head jealousy
means that they're done with it and
they're gonna leave you so don't make
him jealous
don't make him jealous don't do anything
don't go on Instagram don't like any
other girls pics only do what she wants
to do right all the type of stuffs my
thing was never make him jealous that
probably explains why all my so now
you'll never do that again never know
since knowing that jealousy is a very
healthy emotion in my past relationship
I was my ex was my dating coach
assistant she learned game so she would
have to come out to the club with me to
watch me pick up girls and that always
build [ __ ] it I don't give a [ __ ] I'm
just gonna say it good sex yeah and that
always kept a passion going and
everybody was like how long have you
guys been going out cuz you look like
you just started dating a week ago you
have that passion cuz I always showed
her the ability that if she messes up I
could get any other girl and I know any
girl listening to this right now is
gonna be like [ __ ] Cosmo I hate what
he's saying but what women say and what
women do are two completely different
things yeah and I always felt like that
too I'm like I'm doing everything in my
power to make my girlfriend not jealous
but I'm jealous of stuff that they're
doing so it always like I felt like
created a whole tension throughout a
relationship and yes I have to stop you
there you can have you can be jealous
though and then you can have friends
that you emo too but not to her but you
can call David and go bro I'm so [ __ ]
jealous she's going out with this
trainer he has a six-pack looks better
than me and she's putting IG stories
yeah I'm not telling you not to be
jealous cuz now that's [ __ ] up that's
not good advice I'm telling her you need
to eat you need to
her feel jealous it's okay if you feel
jealous you can go to is you know like
you can work on that by yourself
you feel me yeah like you need to be
like why am I feeling jealous oh because
my parents did that my mom okay
and then now you can like really
investigate it and you can work on that
yourself but to keep her hooked she has
to feel that she can lose you and that's
never never what I've tried to do yeah I
know like a lot of dudes who kind of
think like constantly being agreeable is
gonna keep a girl around and I yet to
find that situation where it's ever
worked where it's like yes dear I'll do
what you want dear all this other stuff
right and they and you know when the
break-up happens they have this
conversation of well I did everything
right it's like but did you really like
doing everything right and doing
everything they want are two different
things you know and it's hard for
sometimes these guys to here and I those
are the worst breakup that I've seen
where it's like they've literally felt
that they put this person on a pedestal
and they praised and worshiped them and
they're like well what did I do wrong
it's like I don't think that was the
point of the relationship yeah I don't
think that's what was a factor that was
gonna keep them around forever like
that's not that's not a building block
to a strong rule in my personal opinion
anyways and they kind of built that up
and then when the break-up happens
they're like I did everything right what
happened if Brad Pitt walked in right
now one two three four Mike my business
partners there we all acted very normal
and we're all like like just how you are
with your arms crossed hey what are Brad
we're all like hey what up bro
we want to know the chair if you want to
stand there stand there and we had his
attitude as if like oh [ __ ] by the way
bro
I saw your last movies cool and we're
all lay back like that she would be like
[ __ ] I feel comfortable with these
people
yeah and actually I don't feel like I'm
enough because the last 810 days I've
gone out 40 people have been like oh my
god Brad Pitt oh my god plea and they're
like putting this guy in a pedestal yeah
you have your girl cool I'm glad you're
with me I told my exes I'm glad you're
with me but at any given point in time I
want to let you know that you can
survive on your own and I could as well
too and were
we're cool and you know what you're
doing you're actually being a gentleman
you're letting the girl know that if I
do a douchebag move baby you are okay by
yourself
you do not need me you're actually doing
a good deed to the girl to let her know
you don't have to have a happy life with
me all I'm doing is we're driving in a
car and I'm with you but at any given
point of time if I die if I cheat on you
if I do that I want to let you know baby
you're good good yeah you're actually
doing a good deed to the girl yeah
there's a sense of like wow man I feel
like there's a lot of freedom here
mm-hmm
and if I do break up with Cosmo if I do
break up with David I'm gonna be good
you know what happens when you give
somebody freedom they never want to
cheat you know what happens when you
suffocate someone you get them in a
headlock
where you going you going out with Cosmo
not nope he's a dating coach don't go
out with them they start to feel
cornered and they go why do I feel
cornered and should I be like is my man
that confident mmm you want to give her
that permission hey I'm going to Vegas
cool have fun baby you're not gonna fit
No have fun
she'll come tomorrow go baby I want you
to come with Vegas with me wait a minute
what are you gonna do I guess we're it's
funny because I'm now looking back on it
because my buddy Joe was telling me that
I kind of did attack think that didn't
know cuz I wasn't attracted this girl
but there was this girl in in college at
the dorms and every single guy around
her would fawn over her right any time
she told a shitty ass jokes which wasn't
funny
maybe when using crack the [ __ ] up right
and you know she kind of fed off this
attention consistently and then for me I
had a girlfriend at the time I really
didn't find her that attractive so huh
every morning good morning and I just
walked back into my room right and every
time one day she came up to me she just
goes how come you don't like me and I
was like oh no she what do you mean she
goes well you know everybody else they
say hi to me nah and I could tell you
don't like me because you'll really talk
to me and I was like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about like I say how do you
every morning and it just stuck with her
and then she kept on trying to approach
me just like okay well Dave is being a
swell I'm like
what the [ __ ] in my deal but what he was
telling me was like it's funny because
if he told me that if you wanted to get
her at that point you probably couldn't
could you grab their attention so from
what I said right now what stage do you
think you're at an attraction for from
what I was teaching you guys right out
of the three steps where do you think
you were at at that point yeah I was at
a three yeah cuz she's 20 okay yeah I'm
attractive why are you not into me
those 10 guys David they find me hot
they was like go for them and now don't
we go for them but I have a girlfriend
and if my girl sees you talking to me
right now she might get mad yeah she is
qualifying herself to you right now you
are in the last step of Attraction
before you go into the next step which
is comfort how interesting cuz like at
that moment I'll just like knowing she
kept coming and I just looked at it I
was like and I remember I had a long
conversation with her because you know
she no I wasn't attracted to her but
that's what he was telling me I was like
but if she if you were if you were
single it would have been a different
game and I'm like huh I didn't know I
was doing anything per se cuz I you know
I just didn't like her that way you know
but it's so weird how that was the thing
that grabbed her attention and it wasn't
the multiple guys coming up to her being
like hey like laughing at all of her
jokes which was so odd and you're going
back to the point that I made about
having pre-selection
right he had a girl mmm I don't need
anything from you I already have a girl
that is what I was telling you like
about you it's like you get into your
next relationship make sure you have
three or four women that are your
homegirls that you can go out with cuz
women feel that and they love that you
want to know why the number one need
that a girl has is to feel protected
they want to feel like this guy is not
going to [ __ ] kill me or be crazy so
when you come in with a girl hand in
hand the girl goes oh he's already
pre-screened cuz if he was a psycho he
wouldn't have two girls so these two
girls and check me out check my where
I'm going these two girls did my job for
me cuz they pre-screened David and they
were like put him through all the hoops
David passed all the hoops therefore now
David is hanging out with two three
girls
now that girl goes I don't have to
do that work anymore I know that this
guy is not a psychopath cuz these three
girls wouldn't be with him mm-hmm
it's so there's so much it's it's so
much thought that you don't really think
about right like well I do that's why
it's so interesting how when you could
break it down into those like
specificities cuz the best the hardest
part about all this stuff because it's
that general advice that people give cuz
general advice doesn't really help it's
almost like you know like we let's say
you know when you start at boxing right
so he was Golden Gloves so like so if
somebody came up was like just throw a
punch it's like when you fight just
throw a punch and then use our other arm
to and then duck and don't get hit and
it's like cool I'm gonna get my ass beat
do the ring and see what happens and
that's how it seems very analogous in
that kind of sense because when I when
I'm I'm I was essentially doing the same
thing I was like hey man just go be
yourself go walk in and just chill don't
overthink things and the guy walks in
and they go what the [ __ ] is this guy
talking about how do I do this though
yeah and I'm like oh I figure it out you
were born with it isn't like it I guess
yeah well I'm not guessing you were born
with it like a lot of things that you're
saying you like I would have never
figured out and it took me 23 years to
figure out I wish I knew what I was
doing though you don't know what you're
doing when it was right you go I don't
know why she you found me hot like I
don't know and so therefore you can
replicate it that's the problem you know
when a guy gonna [ __ ] tanked and he
gets really drunk and he goes yeah I got
laid and then we're all but next morning
read Denny's cuz I guess that's where
you go yeah and then we're all hungover
and then I was like bro how did you do
it and he's like I have no idea
you can't replicate it when you don't
know like the breakdown of it you just
go it worked but how do I do it again
man a lot of my relationships - I guess
that feeling we're like I don't even
know how I got this girl how I even
started I really don't know how it
started that's been my feeling on a lot
of my relationships is like I don't know
what I did what made them want to be
with me or all that type of stuff but
it's working so let's let's do it so and
if you are in and
and Alex cuz I know like with him in
like like cold approaches there's
probably the most difficult cuz I could
do one girl and then you know like that
I don't know if I could do like 30 pick
up like David I don't know but our next
episode is gonna be Jenni Santa Monica
promenade approaching eight girls with
for alpha guys tribes like this do a
sweating right now my issue more is like
I don't like I'm not good at reading
signs of like when I should be trying to
make the moves if you get what I'm
trying to say right like I don't know
the signs like if say like if we're if
I'm hanging out with a girl and we're
talking or if I go on dates like the
talking is fine but then I don't really
know what I like you know switch I guess
to me like are maybe I should try to
make it more of like I'm trying to let
you know I'm really actually into you or
I want something from this I just don't
know I don't understand those the best I
should say but don't you think the first
problem would be you demonstrating your
value yes yeah so everything you were
explaining in the beginning right I'm
not I'm not building myself up for them
I'm always trying to just like see them
see them I'm like okay cool yeah that's
cool that's cool that's cool
so if I didn't like you or David right
now I wouldn't be touching you so much
and probably people are wondering why
I'm like vibing out with you guys I
think both of you honestly it's not a
pick-up line have a good energy women do
that innately and it's what I call an
indicator of interest they start to
touch you a little bit they start to
like wanting that connection their neck
opens up this way when they're into you
so they'll be talking to you and
primitively they go like this Wow Cosmo
and they open up their neck another
thing that they do is they start to gaze
at your eyes and they lock eye contact
and you know what happens the more
attraction goes they don't mean to do it
but they go to your lips without wanting
to do it so they're looking at your eyes
and they they're like look I just did a
to David I'm seducing
[Laughter]
but the girl looks like you're in your
eyes and she can help it and then the
next thought is like I wonder what it
would be like to make out with him I
wonder and then so she'll like start to
look at your lips yeah these are accuse
that you need to pick up another thing
would be that she starts to what I call
I will leave an awkward pause to see if
she picks up the conversation mmm so I
will I know that the awkward pause is
not gonna be there if I didn't want it
to be a little stir I'll keep talking
but I'll be like yeah and that's what
happened and I'll leave it there and the
first person to talk after that loses
and let me be very specific for
everybody watching right now oh my god
this guy Cosmo plays too much games it's
too much well this is [ __ ] real life
you want to know how much is this girl
into me right now it's like a business
deal right I think Jordan Belfort talks
about it you do your thing on the phone
and you go Kate don't talk the next
person to talk lose like loses and so
you'll leave these pockets of like I can
be completely quiet like right now don't
want to walk into it and it would be
like so David um so where are you from
and she'll pick up the conversation I
think that's where I lose a lot cuz I'm
nervous of that so you try to fill in
that blank I got nervous when that
awkwardness happened so I always have to
go oh yeah so for sure yeah yeah I
always have to start it so that makes
sense but the kicker is if you haven't
build that attraction with women you can
let that awkwardness happen mmm you have
to build that attraction before you can
consciously go I'm gonna stay quiet
after I go and I went to Miami with
Cosmo you can't do it like the way
you're doing it Yeah right because you
do have to pick it up yeah cuz the girl
is gonna be like bro pick it up yeah you
know what's so interesting I just
thought of something right now too so
like a couple of weeks actually it's
been an ongoing thing so one of Muriel's
first thing that she liked about me that
I don't do now anymore I don't know why
I don't but i all my even all my
girls notice about me right not so much
anymore ever since I got married oh she
goes like she says one of the biggest
thing that she liked about me was that I
always smelled good because I think when
I was a when I was a big guy I wanted to
make sure that I wasn't the big dude
that smell oh so I always smell good I
got it's like specific concoction of
like Cologne I usually and it's a very
unique signature smell that I him and so
recently married oh she goes she goes
you don't smell like you used to anymore
I'm like why I'm not going anywhere and
I just thought of it right now it's my
god really yeah and I was like hold on a
second I was like why don't I just do
that right and I think to like one time
- she actually said I put it on right
and cuz I haven't done it in a while and
I walked out she goes where are you
going and I'm like I'm going outside I'm
gonna go get something she goes but why
you were in the clone it's like we're
gonna meet up I'm like why does that
matter to her so much and I'm like oh
because it was something that she found
attractive about me and now I'm going
outside and winning but most guys not
pointing at you would go oh my god I'm
[ __ ] up why did I make my girl feel
that way you see what I mean most guys
go oh no I'm that was not a good thing
that is a good thing you know because
that means that she's still that much
into you she's attractive she's
captivated if a girl didn't give a [ __ ]
she'd be like put some more Cologne on
and you know what fact here's my credit
card David that's when you're like oh
god I'm in trouble rating that's what
that's my exact reaction I would have bi
oh [ __ ] maybe I shouldn't do that again
oh [ __ ] oh oh [ __ ]
maybe my bad guys walk the [ __ ] I would
wash the [ __ ] off but again you're doing
with a lot of men don't know how to do
that and I teach that step by step it's
a minimum of like 35 hours and that's
not even enough yeah and that's why we
developed like a literally a monthly
program where the first 30 days is $1.00
so guys can get come into my social
circle yes man and be like holy [ __ ]
this is like very effective because it's
a lot of work and God blessed you bro
for having that I didn't have that you
know guys
the 10-year relationship I was in was my
first girlfriend in my entire life I
swear to god I'm not lying
that was my first relationship Wow ever
I didn't know how to deal with a
girlfriend I didn't know I had mom
issues we talked about it I didn't trust
women
I learned this art form and I go okay
now I know how to handle it it's not
natural it's not god-given I worked hard
to do this yeah yeah yeah and I'm very
flawed and I have a lot to work on but
at least I have a formula where I've
taught like a thousand more than a
thousand guys on how to get their wife
their girlfriend and it feels good so
it's not even just like I guess like in
this turn of like you being a dating
coach right it's it's beyond just
getting the person it's like the healthy
part that you have afterwards that's
very important as well because like even
for me I'm just like going back and I'm
thinking about these interactions that I
had with my fiancee right and I'm like
if I would have just tweaked it just a
little bit here right there it could
have done something else right if I
understood the the Cologne situation a
little more I would have been able to
assess what I was doing a little you
know what I mean and those are the
things that kind of keep things going
but I don't I don't know why you know
and so that's interesting
because I keep having these moments on
my oh that's right every time me like
the first podcast David has like these
epiphanies all the time let me talk
about the clients that I teach that are
women and not only women but like
beautiful girls that are so frustrated
because no guys will approach them oh
that's what I wanted to ask you women
who are very beautiful that make good
money you would be so surprised how
lonely they are yeah why though okay so
yeah that's what that is I'm so glad you
brought that up cuz I actually wanted to
ask you that right so consistently I
have a lot of like home rules that are
very very attractive right hyper
confident and they would ask me or just
ask for us as friends in general right
they go it's so hard to find a guy right
how come guys don't approach me and I'm
like [ __ ] do you mean no it's like if I
was single right and I found you
attractive you'd be the first person
that I would
but that's like the consistent rhetoric
it's no guys approach me no guys want to
talk to me I'm like [ __ ] are you talking
like that's my response right obviously
I'm friends with them so I'd be like
shut the [ __ ] up
what is that well before I get into that
I want to let the viewers know you see
what he just did right now he David just
said I have a lot of beautiful home
girls now David's fiancee watching this
that is an attraction trigger to her
whether she likes it or not by him
saying that by you you just did what I
talked about earlier the pre-selection
you did it without knowing it you just
did it right now I have a lot of
beautiful girlfriends so now Davis
fiance is like okay what is he talking
about in his podcast and you're building
attraction so I wanted to touch on that
really you did it without knowing that
you're doing it you're doing it [ __ ]
again huh geez Louise interesting but
but um so a lot of beautiful girls have
a very hard time in giving signals to
the guy to walk up cuz the guy looks at
the girl and goes oh my god have so much
anxiety right now there's no way I can
talk to her oh my god I didn't know
she's too beautiful I can't do it so
she's going through a really rough time
to show the guys hey [ __ ] I'm lonely
I'm horny no guys no guy wants to walk
up to me because they're too scared hmm
and if they make good money every guy is
like well I can't afford her
I can I can keep her if I go to dinner I
can't even pay for her bill she drives a
Maserati how am I gonna hang with her
and so it's a it's a catch-22 for a girl
when is it last time that you've seen a
beautiful a really hot girl going I want
to make a million dollars this year so I
can get a fine guy never probably
yesterday for me when's the last time
you've seen a guy going bro I want to
kill it but I want to make millions dude
so I'm getting some [ __ ] bro so I get
like a really beautiful girl all the
time so they're not built that way so
when they do have that success the fame
the power a lot of money they don't know
how to they don't know how to engage is
it like is it because you think a lot of
guys are intimidated
100% mmm because it's already like it's
a girl and then it's a girl with
everything that I thought I should have
together that would probably be like me
in that situation Oh
cause like for me I'm just like see you
know and then I just get whatever that
have a few drinks and I move on you know
yeah I know we can figure that out David
in our next podcast of David's for real
from what he just said [ __ ]
Santa Monica or a cosmic old on bro I
said like a preset pickup line I get
nervous I'm like oh [ __ ] like if I have
a couple of drinks that's you know I I
always have to do that though like for
sure you know when I say I approach
women like when I was younger I was
always a little buzzed because I needed
that little liquid encouragement so I
could say [ __ ] it let's just see what
happens and obviously two hours around
guys that also had my mentality so we
were kind of like psych ourselves up and
then we would all go out and then see
what happens yeah if it was just me by
myself I think my confidence would have
been shot in half but because I had
other dudes who kind of like I learned
from I guess we would just go out and do
it together we would just see what
happens so I think I also had guys who
were very supportive of that they would
be like okay tonight you know we're
gonna hit the club out in Davis you know
there's a bunch of college I was in
college at the time - in college and
they're like we're just gonna see what
happens whatever [ __ ] it and then
whoever got the girl of dance with them
talk to them it was like cool we got we
got our work done we got what we needed
and then sometimes we smash them
Hollywood that's about it so you're
saying that the guy friends you went out
with it was all about who can [ __ ] first
or get the number or what are you
talking about cuz I'm about to get into
a really good point right now I think
for me it wasn't the [ __ ] it was just to
see if I could just grab a girl's
attention for some of them it was you
know I mean for then they wanted to [ __ ]
that night for me I just wanted to see
if I could get a girl to talk to me you
know you know how much fun it would be
if we went out tonight and we bet a
hundred dollars and who can get rejected
the worst
know how open that would make us we
would be like okay I want a hundred
bucks and we're gonna go and talk to
women on such a independent outcome
meaning that like I have no there's no
way this is gonna work out and you know
what happens a girl feels and she goes
what's your name
like where are you from yeah so when you
have an outcome that you're dependent on
the outcome hey bro we will go out
tonight man we all got some numbers we
don't [ __ ] you put so much pressure and
anxiety on your social circle go out
with all your guy friends to be like
guys we need to get rejected twelve
times before we even like talk to a girl
and it opens up your group so much more
oh and that goal image there's less of
course I'm gonna get rejected so there's
a high success rate in that we like the
mentality should always have always when
I go out with my guys they're like oh
we're going out with Cosmo he's like one
of the best in the world you know the
first thing I tell him I'm gonna get
rejected three times right now and
you're like what like yeah let's do
gonna happen yeah no you wanna what
nothing well it doesn't happen we're
like well I want to be so cocky right
now but I mean the fact that I have the
mindset of like yeah I reject me the
girl like is really open yeah cuz I who
are you that's all fascinating yeah cuz
I think when I was younger and we would
we would have our bunch of friends and
we would go out specifically me and my
buddy gob Oh like he's my best friend
we were we were the duo he would go he's
like literally the version of me he's
just black you know and so and honestly
like his confidence is even past mine
like I would watch him work and then I
would just take a bit of his confidence
and learn what he did how do you how do
you define confidence I'm curious about
that cuz we talked about that last time
like what like what makes somebody
confident like you said he's confident
meaning that he can go to a girl get
rejected and come back to me like I'm
okay bro or like what what made him come
it's almost like he doesn't when I would
see him work it would just be like
there's no game plan like that's how it
would seem like in my head right so when
I see him come up like here's here's the
best example ever I laughed at this dude
so [ __ ] hard because I've seen him
like hit on girls or just
I did I get their number but he didn't
think twice about it he was just himself
and he would speak so for example we're
at subway cloud this guy who bought this
[ __ ] till this day but he has a bad
story about me too
but we're at subway and he walks up to
this girl she's making a sandwich in
mind you this girl at a subway was
[ __ ] beautiful like kind of like
stunning I was like oh [ __ ] and he just
walks up to her he goes you have the
most beautiful eyes I've ever seen right
and she just goes okay he goes hi and he
gets us and she walks away and I died
laughing cuz I was like bro what the
[ __ ] was that just get your [ __ ]
sandwich and go but he would do that
multiple times right and then it would
work so it's not like his approach was
wrong it's just that that was just the
probability of that maybe it wasn't the
setting maybe she wasn't feelin him but
I started to realize like watching him
and how he would go in without doubting
himself and I think that was a thing
that would just grab girl's attention
right his approach was totally wrong mmm
100% wrong hi he was getting away with
was the fact that heating give off
thought and he would go to the next
person but if I told him and you know
I'm being very dramatic right now but
I'm like yo your mom is going to die if
you don't if you don't add of the three
girls you don't get this girl he would
change his approach the fact that he was
confident was like I use I kind of
nailed it before he said it he didn't
care if he got rejected yeah but to
compliment a girl on her beauty is my
biggest pet peeve ever hmm
you don't compliment a girl on their
beauty when you approach her you
compliment her on something that she had
to work for therefore she's gonna go out
she took 20 minutes to think about what
high heels do I want to wear what dress
do I want to wear so if you go yeah I
got it I got to tell you I'm here with
my buddy David I appreciate your fashion
like that's relation a good life yo the
sandwich that you made me like that in
my life
and then she's like okay where do I suck
your dick
not a single man told me that my turkey
sandwich game was like literally that's
the concept of it's like whatever the
girl had to work for she would
appreciate that a lot more therefore I'm
gonna make another analogy a lot of guys
that I coach um I was about to say the
famous people but like they're they're
like father and mother really big actors
they never had to work for the money so
they were given that so they don't
appreciate that rather people that have
to do a podcast for ten would you know
do all this stuff when they get that
money you worked for it you appreciate
that a lot more same thing for women
know if they had to work for something
you say appreciate your fashion you have
good energy that that is the way to go
that's good to know because I feel like
that's like the standard thing to do
right oh let me go compliment her on how
pretty she is are all that type of stuff
yeah cuz I think if I if I look back and
I say when I was mmm I think you know
young age you know 18 and younger right
I I think I was always scared of because
of how unconfident I was about my
approach because I didn't want to come
off as creepy
then I anymore I feel like that's the
death word for guys if a girl calls you
a creep it's like almost calling us like
a rapist I wanna I wanna [ __ ] because
I I want to remember too that you know
this approach of me just like not caring
so much took time right because you know
high school David was not this way you
know high school David had one girl that
he wanted and then when I got her it
reminds me of your situation right so
when I when I received I did that where
I made her seem perfect so when she left
me I mentioned this on the podcast when
she left me I felt that my value was in
her so if she you know right have you
said there and so I lost value of myself
so when she was like David I don't want
to be with you anymore because then I
was like oh I don't have meaning because
my meaning you and so that was like the
biggest it took me like I say two years
to get over and those two years of my
life was some of the worst moments of my
life because I didn't understand how
my value and so she was the biggest
blessing in disguise because because I
experienced that I was like wait a
second you're a [ __ ] loser
why don't you value yourself first
before you go ahead and try to seek that
as somebody else and I had this moment
and it's many pious mother so there was
a point where she she ended up being
with somebody else that was trying to
get with her while we were together
oh right and that [ __ ] devastated me
because that [ __ ] was a loser
okay so I was like out of all the people
you could have gotten why this cuz he
was a loser and you got with him that
makes me dirt around and I'm gonna go in
through a depression for two years go
[ __ ] yourself that's what it made me
feel like and I was so [ __ ] torn
about that [ __ ] but I remember there was
a moment where she and I I desperately
was trying to get her back right for the
next year and a half because we were
best friends before we got together and
so at this moment I just because I
remember this day like it was yesterday
it was I I was taking her to to
Community College after I left
UCR I went to Community College and then
she was there too so we lived close to
each other and I wanted to develop this
friendship again after we broke up that
I would take her to in to class cuz I
wanted to get close to her right again
she wasn't interested in me but she
looked at me one day and she goes you
know you're really kind of kind of
annoying and I stop for a second and I
when I looked that I was like annoying
and it made me mad and I was like what
do you mean I was like you're kind of
obnoxious and I remember when she said
that I was mad because what she said was
true it wasn't because she said
something rude is because what she said
was true I was begging for this girl's
attention so [ __ ] hard that was so
obnoxious and at that I remember that
moment so well because I was like David
you are not gonna be that guy anymore
take a look at yourself what the [ __ ]
are you doing man and so when they broke
up I remember this moment so well she
came to my house and she was like hey so
I broke up with him and I looked at her
I was like that's cool why are you
telling me right and she goes well like
you know I just you know we're just not
working out anymore so you know like I
just wanted somebody to come to and I
was like you
came to the wrong door as I why are you
here and then it kind of like I could
tell it irritated her a little bit and I
was is so interesting where I had that
moment and I was like I've been playing
this whole thing wrong you know what I
mean like I thought once again that me
being the agreeable guy taking her to
school doing all the stuff trying to be
the important person in her life was
gonna create value and it did it and
that was the turning point for me where
I was like you know what dude you're
doing this [ __ ] all wrong how did you
realize you're doing it wrong like that
I feel like that's very impressive like
I like how did you do that
I think it's just you know I talked
about that personality of I don't want
something to have control over me as
long as I recognize that I'm I have
something controlling me I'm like I want
to take that power back got it she she
was taking that power for me yeah and I
allowed it to happen so it was that from
that moment on I started saying [ __ ] it
I'm just gonna try to date whoever and
see what happens so like the first I
remember the first girl that I
approached was in it was at CRC it was a
white girl I've never been with a white
girl before right and I was like I'm
gonna trying to hit on this girl and I'm
just gonna see what happens and it
wasn't that great it was a little longer
than I thought it would take what was
your opening line uh-oh I just asked her
if she wanted to come study with me
after in class and I kind of developed
the relationship that way didn't work
out cuz it was fun but we still ended up
friends but that was the moment I was
like I didn't die you know it's like hey
you didn't die let's see what happens
again I got rejected multiple times
after that III just got lucky with her I
guess but after that when I went to a
different class I tried it with somebody
else struck out struck out struck out
struck out I think I struck out like a
gajillion times after then I got
somebody else to find me attractive
again but that moment what there was was
the biggest learning lesson is because
every person that I was with I was
trying to I gave them too much power it
was like you are my value you know and I
think that was the biggest mistake that
I made yeah
so are you having any kind of epiphanies
right now of course the biggest thing
was like the jealousy thing in that type
of stuff cuz like that is literally my
mindset and
all my past relationship so when you
were saying that I might only [ __ ] cuz I
was jealous of her and she was dealt
with me look at my very first girlfriend
I don't think she gave a [ __ ] what I did
but then I think I gave away too much
[ __ ] about what she did though hmm yeah
yeah it's that was like the biggest one
for me I wanna go I want to make a time
machine so I can go back
[ __ ] myself up huh yeah therapy how
fascinating like I'm seeing myself a lot
of my former self in him you know yeah
yeah I mean we should do something where
I take you out one night and I kind of
like give you give give you a little
sample like you know 10% of what I coach
and I think I can genuinely change your
life I would love that and I want to be
there I'm just gonna be that connection
every wined real quick I can't believe
we just said that I know I can change
your life I said I think I know for a
fact because I can already pinpoint
everything that you're resisting so you
would go from a to being like Cosmo you
really go to your genius and we talked
about it would David to be you're gonna
be like get the [ __ ] away from me I'm
gonna fight you right now because I'm
going through all your darkest fears to
see going Cosmo
I'll kill someone for you I love you
it's like in the middle you're gonna go
get out of here dude cuz on you like you
know everybody knows is on the other end
of fear is your wildest dreams so I'm
making you walk into fear all the time
no I mean yeah you know I'll expose
something about myself a last podcast I
told David I'm like I love to walk into
fear all that and then you know I'll
emote to YouTube whatever or wherever
we're at right now I don't like [ __ ]
elevators myself because I know it's
coming out of some fighters podcast so
like I text David I'm like yo what I
text you you say can we walk up some
stairs because I have it they speak
about
that tone I said it very confident like
yo you got us stares eyelash actually
we're gonna go like if you want to keep
it real let's just go all the way right
now hold on guys
yo I know this is very random ass
requests dot lol anyways I can go up to
stare anyway I can go up the stairs this
time lol elevators sometimes give me the
heebie jeebies devar responds sure lol
haha and I respond with a video cuz I'm
like [ __ ] David and then he responds
with it's like oh here I'll make sure
you're safe
oh great [ __ ] my life why did I tell you
but is a whatever so then as I'm coming
up I'm like how to be such a hypocrite
because I'm like all about walking into
fears so I went up the elevator I should
I use to be scared of elevators too but
just because when I was young someone
told me that a story about people like a
gas line broke in an elevator and you
like burned everybody's skin off so I
used to be terrified to hear that bro
and I got stuck in elevator one it was
it was weird like I don't know why I
didn't freak out but I was like oh oh
it's cuz they you had the button and
somebody's talking to you mm-hmm so
they're like yeah we're gonna get
something to get you I've never really
had I did have a huge fear of escalators
though yeah the little [ __ ] because
when I was in Korea my shoelace got
caught in a [ __ ] drag me oh I thought
I was coined I've seen that happen
before tuna escalator I saw a little kid
at this uh Best Buy used to work out in
the mall their shoe got caught like
right at the top and they're like got
their foot in and I think their foot had
broken but I was like oh that's what I
was scary I got lucky because my uncle
grabbed me and he just snapped shoelace
off but it was like Korean Korean
escalators do the best [ __ ] is they're
powerful as [ __ ] and make a way faster
than American escalators like a like an
American was nice and smooth like the
Korean
you would if you jumped they would
[ __ ] shoot you through the [ __ ]
roof they don't give a [ __ ] about
people's safety in that country dude
shut us my people don't talk [ __ ] about
my people because I've got a lot of DMS
in Asia community loves me um so yeah
isn't that crazy PTSD yeah
like you get I got stuck an elevator and
then it lingers on in your life and that
happens in a lot of people's
relationship you know I'm going through
a divorce I got a breakup so I'm a loser
I'm never gonna get a girl like that so
you get PTSD you go if she did it every
girl is gonna do that I have a fear of
elevators I go every elevators gonna
break down on me oh so now crazy like
that's how it happens that's PTSD right
there to go back to the to the to the
girl thing right so like when when these
girls talk about you know and obviously
my response like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about right I mean what would be
like a the solution for them because
it's like if you are emitting this this
alpha woman thing which is a quality
that I really enjoy like I like alpha
women who get their [ __ ] done those are
the ones that attract me the most what
what is what would their solution be to
that problem then so what they need to
do would all my clients do that are
women is you need to connect with the
guy on a logical level not like kind of
expecting all that but I tell my clients
that are women to go up to the guy and
to be like hey straight up I think
you're cute you just wanted to come over
and say that or pick out something about
it is alpha L oh I love that shirt
where'd you get it
and then she's taking initiative the
guys like oh uh I got it at hum za Zara
do you like and she said yeah to keep
her cool give the guy validation
approval build him up and then let him
shine there's a lotta really talented
actors and actresses in Hollywood going
to auditions [ __ ] breaking down and
they could be Daniel day-lewis and like
Meryl Streep but they go into an
audition room and the casting director
is like okay who's next let's go and
you're putting that pressure so you're
not able to unravel the talent they have
to unpeel the confident alpha guy by
giving them approval then the guy feels
confident and goes okay now let me show
you why I'm gonna
man do you so recently so I had a buddy
who who recently split up with his girl
right and when she was I guess it was
the advice I was giving was something
along those lines and it was only
because I know who this guy this guy is
like one of those guys that's he's hyper
logical right
he's mr. macho macho guy and so what I
was telling her that well they broke up
because she couldn't do this part for
him and I when I was telling her was
like you know the way that you approach
him and the way that you speak to him
you don't allow him to be God yeah you
don't allow him to you gotta let him
talk and let him demonstrate his high
value like let him showcase to you why
he's a confident guy but if you keep
telling him yeah oh yeah so I had my
Maserati downstairs I had my own company
the guy is like digging his own grave
right there let him build himself up the
girl needs to be like so ya talk to me
I'm curious about you I know it's weird
I'm walking up to you right now girls
don't do that but like yeah talk to me
and the guy will be like okay well I
have my podcast I'm on you too and then
let the guy open up that's not because
yeah cuz I see I couldn't use those
words exactly right and I could
understand why she left confused because
I was giving her an example I was like
for example I told her the way that she
speaks to him you kind of speak to him
like he's your child and it probably
[ __ ] with his head a little bit right
so for example she was it was a cold day
and she's like give me an example of
like well this is here's an example she
it was a cold day and when he was about
to leave you said it's cold outside take
your jacket I was like how come you
can't rephrase that it is like hey is it
kind of cold outside do you think you
need your jacket and let him make that
choice but when you speak to him you
give him commands and so when you do
that it [ __ ] with him a little bit I
was like I know this guy he's mr. Alpha
dude and he's mr. solutions guy so when
you take that away from him you also
take a little bit of his manhood away
not a little bit you take a lot of a lot
of his manhood and you nailed it
one of my clients went went through that
and I said tell him baby I'm going to
take your jacket with us just in case
you're cold
I'll carry it that's what the girl said
just say that to him yeah so then the
guy was like babe
I'll take my jacket I'll carry you want
me to carry anything and the guy ends up
doing the work that she wanted for him
to do your the girls baiting him yeah
baby I'm gonna take your jacket for you
cuz you might be cold if not I'll carry
it so now the guys like okay and he
doesn't feel like he's being talked down
the girls like I got your back I'm right
or die I'm right or die like don't worry
about it I'm not putting you down I'm
not I mic me I like might make more
money than you and I'm an alpha girl and
all that but I got your back baby I'm
ride or die and I'm gonna carry this
jacket and you might not be cold but I
care about you so I'll have it the guy
opens up yeah cuz I I feel - and you
could correct me if I'm wrong I feel
like sometimes with even with me when I
when I speak to my fiance right we get
into a lot of fights we'll get a lot of
fights but when we do fight it's more
like it's because we're not speaking the
same language
I'm logical and she's emotional and then
we're trying to talk to each other like
this rather than seeing where we're
talking in and meet up and there so I
was like oh if you're speaking from an
emotional sense maybe I should connect
with you there or if I speaking
logically you should talk to me here but
it's always like this and this that's
what it feels like anyways girl walks in
your girlfriend and she slams the door
she looks at you you're like hey babe
she's like hey how are you babe you okay
yeah yeah yeah I'm good she goes to the
kitchen David yeah babe the dishes are
all over the place right now do you not
care about a relationship like literally
do not want to work at all to be a
better boyfriend she's speaking through
it emotionally so now you have to go
wait a minute
I can't logically tell her most guys do
this babe it takes 45 seconds to wash
the dishes or guys go babe I can wash
your dishes tomorrow morning nobody's
coming over what's the big deal you see
how that happens this we're logical we
go why why you trippin is for watching
my security cage it was like a
conversation yesterday and she was
that's exactly what happened because she
say then you can't do that because
logically you're right and alright let
me let me go back real quick when you
get into an argument with someone and
then the person goes like this watch I'm
gonna make everyone mad right now the
person goes you know what you know what
David you win you're right you win then
the other person goes no no no no I
don't want to win it's about you not
knowing what I want and then the other
person goes no no you win
you can't look you can't do that you
can't say you win cuz then they go oh
he's only doing that to say that like he
wants any argument you have to go babe
I'm really tired right now like I'm
exhausted
um is there any way you can just cuddle
or come to the couch and I'll if it's
okay with you I can wash the dishes
tomorrow now she goes alright give me a
blanket you go okay babe get the blanket
she'll sit next to you then she'll go
like this I had a fucked-up day I'm
sorry babies I'm cranky you go all good
and it's completely diffused let her
call herself out
let her go [ __ ] being a [ __ ] you go a
little bit but I still love you
women will call they will go [ __ ] I'm
being wrong right now emotionally
they'll go [ __ ] I'm being a little bit
of a [ __ ] guys is well to that have a
high EQ emotional intelligence to go
what the [ __ ] why am i barking at my
girl right now oh because I got cut off
by this Romanian dude we got it we got
out we almost got him to fight I don't
want to tell her I got into a fight then
I went to Ralph's they told him and then
so you build all that up and you don't
want to tell your girl mm we do the same
[ __ ] I come in and be like baby I'm
gonna let you know right now I'm in a
[ __ ] bad mood so give me like ten
minutes cuz I'm just in a bad mood has
nothing to do with you now your girl is
in the game with you now she knows oh
we're in it together and we can both be
in a bad mood I feel like that's really
hard for a lot of guys you know like
like ninety-nine well I'm exaggerating
but over half of our population of guys
don't do that
back to you with you not being able to
emote right no no I'm good you know I
don't want to do all that like you guys
need to have the permission to go I need
to talk about my emotions I need to let
it out somewhere
mmm-hmm that is that's like something
that's really hard for me too it's like
like I could do it well with other
people
but for some reason showing that to her
it's very hard like when I when I was
going through a lot of the emotions
because of like the BLM stuff like I was
angry all pissed like she could see it
in me - yeah like she chose me
so like I'm waking up and I'm just like
like seething like I don't think I am
you know but I'm kind of shown that and
she goes you're in a bad moment I'm fine
I'm telling I'm okay like I'm good you
know cuz it my mother wait a minute
David we're gonna go into David's uh I'm
gonna like psychoanalyze you right now I
feel like you did know you were in a bad
mood yeah I think I I know I'm in a bad
mood but it's more like you don't want
to tell I don't want to but okay cuz you
you know you're in a bad yeah okay and
so when she tells you baby are you in a
bad mood you're aware that you're in a
bad mood but you're like if I tell you
it might open up a judgmental argument
by her going but David baby why are you
letting social media get to you so
therefore you go I'm not about to get
into a judgemental argument so I'm gonna
tell my girl I'm good yeah open up that
can of worms like I'm not gonna get the
support that I need and I might even get
angry or you know literally I'm gonna
tell you what to do babe I'm in such
felt that in relationships too before
actually so yeah sorry to cut you off
back to you but because I want to hear
what you're saying but for David baby
I'm in a bad mood I know this is
illogical and I just don't want you to
judge me I don't want you to give me
advice I just want you to be there for
me I'm [ __ ] pissed that this black kid
died today and it's getting to me and it
shouldn't and I'm emotional right now
and it has nothing to do with you and I
don't want advice but just if you can
just give me like an hour to decompress
and I'm [ __ ] mad yeah and then a girl
your girl's gonna go okay babe you
anything for breakfast yeah but you got
you got
/ I didn't want advice I just need to
get it off my chest as black kid who got
killed is [ __ ] killing me why did his
[ __ ] cop kill that black kid yeah why
and then it's kind of like setting her
up for that instead of just like the
moaning it out and expecting them
results say like this is what I need
from you here are the boundaries just
respect this and then we'll be okay
hmm I'll try to [ __ ] out yeah so what
are you saying I know just like how I've
had that before in relationships like oh
are you mad no I'm good no I'm good but
deep down inside and I'm like no I'm
[ __ ] pissed off and it could be like
[ __ ] I think now that you've talked
about the jealousy and all that stuff
I'm like sitting here thinking I'm like
putting [ __ ] together like [ __ ] maybe
that's why I was acting like this or
won't be that's why I did like that I
think that was a lot of it too because I
was always trying to be like I don't
want to act like I'm being jealous and I
don't want to make her jealous so I was
always just like bottling up absolutely
everything absolutely everything so
anybody oh I can tell you madam like no
I'm good I'm good or if they will go do
something that would say make me jealous
right I'm lying now I'm like no I'm not
jealous go ahead go no no no no so now
when you're saying all this [ __ ] I'm
like it's all making sense when you're
saying all of it but it makes more sense
when I hear you guys talking about it
I'm sitting here like [ __ ] that's
exactly like what he's gonna do I'm like
I'm Rico I'm recollecting all this old
stuff and I'm like oh [ __ ] that's that's
that moment that I had you know the only
way that I think why people pay me money
is I can go dead up like God honest
truth you can probably figure this out
by yourself but it's gonna take you
three or four years with me hiring me
probably two days but I'll go even
further I don't even think a lot of
people can't figure it out that's the
thing like and I'm being very optimistic
yeah I genuinely don't think that a lot
of people can because if that was the
case right I like me like I didn't know
these
like I'm figuring these things that as
we're speaking right cuz this is stuff
that I would probably ignore and then it
would come up I don't know three years
from now four years from now but then it
takes somebody who has perspective and
understands where you're coming from to
really bring this out this is why I
really [ __ ] with therapy a lot right a
lot of people have and this is what this
really is like you as a dating coach
you're a dating therapist really is what
when it kind of boils down to right cuz
you're not really teaching you how to
fool a girl into liking you you're
actually working with the person here
first before you go out there yeah so
it's you first and then we figure out
the rest because right now I think a lot
of guys do this where they blame
everybody else and they don't take
personal responsibility for the
situation that they're in they go I'm in
the friend zone because of this I'm
doing it's in it's like because of that
person like I don't know what they're
doing wrong but it's like hold on a
second let's work here first and then we
could figure out what's happening else
out there you know hey Cosmo I cannot
afford your course is too much money my
rebuttal how much time do you have left
on this planet cuz that's what you
should be thinking about you're 28
you've gone through three breakups you
want it you're gone through a deep
depression in two years
why if I want to learn how to swim I'm
gonna hire a [ __ ] coach that can
teach me I don't want to drown in the
ocean for a year let you know how to do
it
teach me that's why I think that like
come on guys like if you're having a
hard time just fight don't have to be me
if you don't like me just find somebody
else that can empower you and teach you
step by step on how to do it most people
don't know this the average watch this
don't even think about it both of you
you go first what do you think the
average lifespan of a human being is how
many days don't think about you oh yeah
well 20,000 for their whole life of
their whole life I don't know I okay so
how about you [ __ ] are smart
because when they asked me that I was so
in denial of like life being very long
I answered 300,000 hours in the reality
show I did is 28,000 days so you guys
are pretty
here so really didn't work on you guys
but a lot of people I guess for myself
I'll speak for me think that you have a
lot more time on this earth than you
really do when you focus on like it's
too much money I don't want to do that
course I don't want to do that when in
retrospect is like so you went to the
bar you spend 40 bucks then you went to
go get a stripper it's like nothing of
it it doesn't make sense you know it's
like you spent two years 80 grand and
you and you're still stuck and so you
know I would tell a lot of people like
if you're stuck take that leap find a
coach and and you know get it fixed you
know I'll go further than that because
cuz I used to be in that realm as well
right like I didn't I'm not trying to
say this like in a product that I'm not
selling anything so it's like I I
believe in that only because of
something as simple as health right
everybody thinks that they know how to
lose weight right everybody thinks that
they know how to get buff and fit they
go the information is out there why do I
need a coach and if that was the case
everybody would have done it right now
right the the the problem with thinking
that is that is there there's a million
pieces to this [ __ ] puzzle right but
you don't know where to start and that's
what it is to have all this information
out there whether it's coaching for
powerlifting whether it's to be a
martial artist or whatever if this was
true I could look up every single
tutorial about how to box right now yeah
and I would be an amazing boxer Yeah
right when I first was training with
Nick man I'm not gonna I said this on
the podcast before I marvel at that I
was slick before I got there right but
then I recorded myself and I looked at
this video I was like yo who slow this
video down video footage why is this
[ __ ] so slow and I look back in
it now it's because I went into
something thinking that even though I
told him I didn't I in the back of my
mind I thought I knew more than I
actually did and I did it you know so
when you put value on like something as
simple as this to people who say they
can't afford a gym they can't afford
these things that are about mental
health and wealth you have any idea how
much time you spend saving up for stuff
for physical objects in your life a pair
of shoes like when somebody tells me
that they can't afford like a gym
membership right that's about $70 a
month I guarantee you within that week
you've already spent 70 bucks on food
going out to eat already which is
something that's finite when you take
courses or you take stuff that betters
yourself this is stuff that you take
with you for the rest of your [ __ ]
life that's why I started traveling it
wasn't the money that I spent that went
away it was the experiences that I
gained that I could constantly look back
on these are the stuff that adds value
to your life and it's so important that
you mentioned that life is short it is
[ __ ] short it's a great perspective
is - I didn't realize that my parents
were gonna pass away until I got older
when I'm a kid I think that mom and dad
are always gonna be there forever for
the rest of my life and when you see
them age as you get older then you're
like oh [ __ ] life is finite so when you
become it when you're if you're younger
- and you're in a situation right now
where you feel like everything is gonna
stay the same you're gonna have the
rudest [ __ ] away me when you're older
you see mom and dad get older there are
dreams that you thought you were gonna
have that you don't have and you look at
your life now and you go [ __ ] what what
did I spend my time with where did I
spend my [ __ ] money
and I think for me because me moving out
to LA and me kind of taking these risks
me traveling really opened up my mind to
where I put my money so that's why when
I spend money on my neck coach on my
neck on my coach it's been this is the
first time I actually lost weight
because there was an accountability
there there was somebody who taught me
the ropes that was with me along the way
because I always told myself I could do
without anybody else but it wasn't true
some people can and you guys fantastic
but for those of you out there who have
tried constantly and you failed
why not ask for help why not I don't
know spend some money and get the help
that you [ __ ] need what's why does
that make you feel like and I think a
lot of people - when it comes to dating
coaches they go other people didn't need
it why do I need it like what is he
gonna really teach me it's like dog if
that was the case then why are dating
coaches around you know um Conor
McGregor said I have been [ __ ] up go
to YouTube watch him on Anthony Robbins
he realized how much money LeBron James
was spending on himself you saw that
right in Conor I don't want to say it
again coz there's a girl that made fun
of me about my chills and that's common
I told Mike I wouldn't do it but I'm
getting chills so Conor McGregor was
like I've been [ __ ] up
I've only been spending like little
amount of money on myself and I've been
spending on cars and all that and LeBron
James you guys can google that I want to
[ __ ] it up but millions of dollars on
himself working on my leg therapy all
that so then when Conor McGregor
realized that he started spending so
much money on himself
you are the [ __ ] product you
don't need to buy a Lambo invest in
yourself and then that is gonna
quadruple your income your social skills
all of the above get a solid team that
can empower you and coach you and the
second thing I wanted to comment was on
the fact that like the 20,000 days right
like life is very short when you're 90
and 95 years old you're only going to be
doing two things regret or when you were
younger you felt the pain and you did
that he took action and there's no
regret you know for example you want to
lose weight you got a diet you're gonna
feel the pain [ __ ] call me night though
a 900 calories I can't eat a whopper off
[ __ ] that you're gonna feel that pain
but later on you won't feel that regret
or you can lie now homie I'm good I
don't need Cosmo dog I got I got this
[ __ ] lock down and you can hide it
meaning that you're not gonna experience
me pushing you but then you're gonna be
older going oh my god I never got
married yeah I never experienced love I
hated my whole life so my objective in
life is to get men to experience the
minimal regret that they can and like
that that you know one of the biggest
ways I lost weight was listening to this
guy David Goggins and he always and he
always preaches this concept of like you
know pain just being a temporary
roadblock to success right a lot of us
don't want to experience pain a lot of
us don't want to go through hardships
but we want all the glory and when in
the [ __ ] has that ever happened in life
[ __ ] never people don't become great
at what they do by doing absolutely
nothing and
kind of do the same thing over and over
and over and you expect a different
result and that's the definition of
insanity you're a [ __ ] crazy person
you're a crazy person to think that you
were gonna get a different result
no I love it I love it Alex man we got
good I want to see it I wanna see it do
it I just want observe yeah we got a wee
amen you know I'd be done to help you
I'd be great well guys that wraps up
this episode of the genius brain podcast
love you in the information right now I
was like okay damn but but I can see why
and not trying to sound like trying to
hit on you or anything but I can see why
women would feel very comfortable with
you because you're like a very good
listener you have like a very calm
energy about you so I can see why a girl
would be like you know what I'll get
into a relationship with him because you
you I like just being here with you I
want to be your friend
but the thing that you're missing is
like that bad boy element that edginess
to be like I might lose him and that's
if if we work together what I would add
to your arsenal for sure
I'll [ __ ] love it Cosmo where can
they find you at coach Cosmo on
Instagram and then Mike I have my guy
back here my marketing genius at yes man
no yes man we'll put the link below
yeah well have that we'll have the link
below for you guys to find it was in the
previous video as well it will also be
on the podcast and then Alex where can
they find you Instagram all my stuff
twitch all that stuff just lifts got LIF
fgo DeeDee
that's why ladies here I live God you
know hey let's go the live guys the new
single to Spotify ha ha ha so we'll see
y'all next time peace